[Music]  [Music]  he's just a wonderful first of all it's  a basic right here we are discussing  things that are really important if you  want to have your brain refreshed come  to howlite get it make the argument you  have the debate and you have the courage  to stand up and say what you believe in  and hope to change minds most of the  major issues we have now is that we  don't know how to tolerate each other's  interpretations the challenge is  actually an important in fact the most  important part of the process that is  humanity for me  often they find that ideas seem crazy  turn up actually be right there's a big  story here that very few people are  aware of  [Music]